on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle things can only get worse
also the bank of england is saying we'll
have a panel of money saving experts to
get you through the cost of living
crisis
conservative mp and chair of the defense
select committee whiplash tobias elwood
will be keeping us all in line tonight
as he discusses the growing threat from
china
and is it the summer of 1976 all over
again first the record temperatures and
now how british is this a hosepipe van
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends so let's go
straight in with that cost of living
crisis the biggest single issue
affecting every single person watching
this tonight yes even you morgan because
apparently nobody's going to be immune
if it gets as bad as the bank of england
forecast this morning they gave arguably
the gloomiest prediction this country
has ever had with a year-long recession
to start by the end of this year
inflation to peak at 13
and unemployment expected to double in
the next three years plus an interest
rate raise of 0.5 that's the first time
since 1995. so everybody's walking
around going is it time to panic what
can we do about it well on this show on
my watch we're going to keep calm and
carry on so welcome to my don't panic
room
[Music]
did you like that if i could explain to
you what putting this show together
tonight has meant because my first guest
justin ercart stewart investment manager
and business commentator has just walked
on this set in the last 10 seconds don't
die the cost of living crisis meant
there was no petrol in your car i also
welcome gemma godfrey and also sue
hayward we're going to talk about ways
that
for me
to start tonight i want to put it in
layman's terms okay
we see all these figures thrown out
inflation here morgan
put it in layman's terms what does today
mean for the men and women up and down
this country who want to know in their
pockets right the reality is what
they're going to see is the value of
them their money is devaluing really
quite fast at the moment because
actually what's happening to the economy
it is still growing but we've got
politicians who should be focusing on
the wrong issues at the moment not
focusing on the areas where the economy
is growing we're focusing on some of the
old industrial areas as opposed to
actually some of the technology and
those elements meanwhile you've got a
chance though i've got a chance of never
quite sure which one he is today um
who's that are we today
and the bank of england bank of england
apparently is independent no it's not um
and so i've actually got the position
where the bank of england is really got
a difficult position because inflation
you're told if you've got inflation you
put interest rates up now hang on good
interest rates up you've got to slow the
economy that's something about that
that's all well and good but let me
treat me as an idiot right
electricity and gas bills 3 300 quid
petrol diesel 2 pounds a liter
a hose pipe ban right you can't take a
flight anywhere
unemployment skyrocketing you can't get
a gp appointment you can't see a dentist
people out there are going where does
this end you say about the figures but
in terms of if you're watching this what
hope have you got what what are you
grasping hold of tonight what you are
actually seeing actually parts of the
economy are still doing really rather
well sydney what a swap you've got the
technology small company technologies
where we actually set up more small
businesses in this country than france
and germany put together
unfortunately we're not very good at
growing them they get to a certain scale
they get bought up by the americans they
go elsewhere so we're really good at and
not necessarily in london you go to the
technology centers around the around the
universities all over the country and
you'll find some really exciting
businesses there they're looking at the
wrong bit that's where the future is
meantime we've got to sort out our other
issues which are frankly those are
problems which are affecting the whole
world you're uh you're an expert i'm not
yesterday i wake up to the fact the bp
in three months makes 6.9 billion pounds
worth of profits energy companies are
raking it and we couldn't get a boss
from a water company tonight to come
anywhere near talking to us and yet
people's water bills people electricity
bills going through the roof what does
the government need to do it needs to
have some proper regulators we've
actually got something that actually has
some teeth as opposed to off what often
offside frankly they don't do very much
we were told when water was privatized
they were going to replace all the
victorian pipes and now we see signs
saying we're investing in 30 years later
to replace all the victorian pipes
someone's got the money and the answer
was it was tend to be those large
institutions so he wasn't fed through
and in the right way and the other thing
i never understand is a price cap
because this is a price cap that
continually moves upwards and a price
cap as well which is actually rare has
bought very little resemblance to
actually what's been happening in the
economy you saw what happened with the
electorate where with the producers
coming through in terms of power you had
the old providers and they had to put
chip in they had to pay for the green
levy in a second then you had a bunch of
i should get rid of that straight away
in my humble opinion well then you had a
bunch of other people coming in who had
no qualifications or experience in how
to actually operate can you give anybody
any hope very quickly yes what you're
finding is that actually the global
economy is still growing despite the
fact that we had a clan pocket though
does it
forget it doesn't may not feel like it
but apparently we've had a pandemic
we've had uh huge this you've got a war
going on and yet despite that the global
economy is slowing but still growing
this is a don't panic room uh i say good
evening to gemma godfrey financial and
personal finance consumer business
expert that's a mouthful what i want is
how the people watching this can can
gain any positivity from tonight what
what can you say to people jenna look
families are really fighting a battle on
all fronts that's why it's unprecedented
because it's you know food prices are
going up trying the the price to be able
to get to work is going up the price to
warm your home is going up and now
obviously today debt is getting more
expensive so it is a really tough time
and i think so the first thing i would
say because i do have three areas i can
give people tips on but the first thing
i would say is there are many families
millions of families who are already
doing everything they can and it's not
helpful for their mental health to say
and here's a list of 10 more things also
there isn't a silver bullet out there
usually i come with lots of tips but
what i would say is this
is it for people because every little
helps the first thing to do is to check
for leaks in your budget so this is the
time to not put your head in the sand
but to go through bank statements see
all the little
free trials that suddenly become paid
for trials use budgeting apps whatever
you can to try because the little bits
can add up i think the second thing is
really important is to speak up because
the biggest risk especially when debt's
getting more expensive is that people
fall into unarranged overdrafts they get
penalties they get late fees and they
fall into debt that gets more expensive
so the energy regulator has come out and
said that energy suppliers um are there
is an obligation for them to provide
payment plans that are affordable and
therefore our people just very quickly
you know we hear lots of stories about
people saying i can't get through i
can't get a response are these companies
being realistic in in chasing this debt
because they know how bad it is will you
get a more sympathetic response do you
think well i think at times like this
again let's let's keep it really
business minded forget the fact that
people want to help people but let's
keep it really business minded it's in
nobody's interest for people to fall
more and more in debt and never get paid
yeah so that's why actually speaking up
earlier quite often there'll be payment
plans and i actually because the third
point i was going to say is being very
wary of deals because what they'll
sometimes do is give people longer to
pay back but maybe you know but if
they're paying back for longer even if
it's a lower at a lower interest rate
over the longer term it could be more
expensive um sue hayward personal
finance and consumer expert as well how
do you see this i mean i i was just
saying to to justin i'm not sure out
there how people feel good about
anything right now it's hard right
absolutely and the fact is that because
everything is going up you know the
pound in your pocket is pretty much by
new zealand right now because the
inflation's eating away at it the food
bills are going up and we were chatting
outside you know it's individual things
that all of us have noticed in our
weekly shop absolutely but you tend to
think i mean mine is cheese cheese
flation if you like you know it's just
the piece of brie i buy in the same
supermarket
what about some tips what about i mean
somebody said to me today well you turn
your thermostat down by two degrees it's
the summer i haven't got me eating on
what can you do do you know what that's
the sort of thing usually in normal
circumstances i would suggest that as a
tip but in the current climate apart
from the fact it's it's obviously summer
it's really not going to touch the sides
of the bills i mean the big thing i
would say is mortgages we know interest
rates have gone up obviously it's not
going to affect everyone if you are um
you know on a fixed rate right now you
won't be affected until your deal ends
but of course when your deal ends you
then got to try and lock in a new one
but it will affect there's around two
million home owners on standard variable
rates you're paying your lenders book
standard rate or if you're on a tracker
rate which means it will affect you and
obviously the lenders will start to come
out if they haven't already in the next
few days putting their rates up so one
thing that you can do is if you really
really are struggling is to speak to
your lender and if you've got a really
good strong track payment record where
you make your payments on time they
might give you mortgage payment holiday
now under the whole coronavirus scheme
that they were obliged to do this under
the government rules that's now stopped
but if you've got a good payment track
record a lot of them will allow you to
stop payments maybe six to 12 months
temporarily of course it's not free cash
you will have to pay the money back it's
interesting if we all assume around this
table that we are we are stretched
everybody is stretched is it time
briefly amongst those us is it time for
the government to do more are there
tools that the government could use now
to make people's lives better because i
hear about the cost of living crisis
every day and i want practical solutions
what can the government do there's some
serious addresses seriously but in terms
of the same way we're dealing with
pandemic and you had to have furlough
juice which no one had heard of before
we need to address this we have never
seen price rises like this when it comes
to power so you need that the action to
be able to provide the
support for the populations to get
through this period it's not good it's
not going to finish within a year may
take 18 months may take two years but it
will come to an end at some stage the
government can provide that sort of
support it has got access cheaper money
that's why we had quantitative easing
you don't use it for everything but this
is a vital moment you see i'd agree with
that it's almost like i want the
government to be on an economic war
footing do you know what i mean to make
it easier for people would you agree
yeah and i also think that what they're
doing is that they're it's like it's
like you know you're bleeding and
they're coming along putting a bandage
on it but what's the reason that we're
actually bleeding so one of the things i
think is important is we need to because
of the lack of competition so many
energy suppliers went bust it means if
you go online you try and find a better
deal there isn't competition there so i
think trying to boost that will be
really important and the second thing is
that while we've seen job losses in the
hospitality sector we're really
stretched in healthcare so i actually
think helping people reskill will also
be really important as well sue to
finish what would you say i would say
with the mortgages one of the things the
government could do is reintroduce the
pressure on lenders to actually allow
people to have the mortgage payment
holiday so it should be there that you
can ask rather than you have to go cap
in hand prove that you've got this
amazing track record because it's almost
it's to say it really it there will come
a point whether it's mortgage companies
credit card companies utility companies
if people can't pay they won't pay and
if they can't pay then i presume the
companies are going to have to find some
sort of middle ground i have to move on
justin you made it in the nick of time
honestly i thought cost a living crisis
you've got no petrol at sue hayward
gemagothy thank you very much today for
joining us right my friends next on
uncensored with no end in sight to the
war in ukraine and with tensions rising
significantly into one could this all
end in nuclear war i will be asking
chair of the commons defense select
committee to buy a sell wood after the
break all of that stay with us i'm
coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
jeremy karna this weekend is the
anniversary of the first use of a
nuclear bomb in hiroshima japan on the
6th of august 1945. a few days later the
u.s dropped a second bomb on nagasaki
estimates are that up to 220
000 people were killed across the two
cities russia has over 6 000 weapons of
mass destruction ready to deploy in the
last few months putin has not shied away
from threatening to push the button
himself but
is this just explosive rhetoric or the
prelude to all out nuclear war i'm
delighted to be joined now by
conservative mp and chair of the defense
select committee tobias elwood tobias
welcome good evening um
we saw pelosi land in taiwan
we saw china the following day military
exercises around the island i'm i'm
fascinated about
the biden response do you think that
china is on the brink of invading taiwan
i don't actually i don't think that's
china's intentions at all we think in
election cycles almost in news cycles
but china will not do today what it can
do a lot easier in five to ten years
time but they are making sure that we
are rattled about it that we're worried
they see this as their backyard and they
want everybody to know that they don't
discover this from a territory
perspective don't forget this is also
allows them to then control the south
china china sea that nine dotted line
that you sometimes see on the map so
that will annoy uh the united states
that's got guam and indeed hawaii as
well but also don't forget that
economically most of the microchips made
you know that are distributed around the
world are all coming from taiwan so if
they grab taiwan they economically have
a stranglehold over the rest of the
world it's it's it's interesting for me
um
do we do the us and the uk recognize
taiwan's independence no we don't we so
what are we invested in there what why
the interest then if we don't recognize
them for those reasons that i've just
said where does china then go relax
because they are militarily economically
technologically they will overtake the
united states in our lifetime we don't
know how to handle that we don't have a
china strategy and that is the problem
we don't have a russia strategy either
we've been dominated by local elections
or national elections here we've been
united states is distracted so is france
and germany where is the western
leadership at the moment it's not there
to be seen when pelosi landed um there
was a lot said and written about biden's
response for me and you're the expert
you know she landed on an air force one
jet it seemed she seemed to be afforded
every attribute of a foreign dignitary
the first and most senior one i think
that u.s politician in 25 years do you
not think that that was antagonistic
towards china and do you think that
biden
through his silence he could have
stopped it or did he support it or does
it suit his agenda so my worry is i saw
this when we went across to the united
states for the defense select committee
is that america is actually obsessed
about taiwan and is actually not seeing
the bigger picture china likes the fact
privately that the world or the west is
concerned about taiwan right because it
distracts china or us looking at china
and all the other things that it's doing
what's going on in hong kong the uyghurs
for example what's happening across the
world with its one belt one road program
china is ensnaring dozens of countries
into debt traps they cannot afford is it
a convenient distraction
and this is the worry i have we are
failing to see the bigger picture what i
see happening at the moment after
afghanistan is both russia and china
taking advantage of the fact that the
west has become more timid more
risk-averse we've lost that cold war
statecraft that we once had to look our
adversaries in the eye and stand up to
them um in terms of putin and
and russia
two questions do you think china would
look at what russia is doing in ukraine
and that might affect what they next do
and also i'm fascinated from you with
your experience he keeps threatening
doesn't he subtly and unsubtly to to use
nuclear weapons we talked about 1945 in
that that intro can you see him ever
pushing that nuclear button let's do
those two things separately firstly
these aren't separate items here you've
got russia and china that are now
working together let's wake up to that
we have two cold wars that are going to
blur into one our world is splintering
to two spheres of competing influence
russia and china are quietly working
together recognizing that they are
stronger together to stand up to the
west they don't like the our
international rules based order they
want it to fall apart they want it to be
wobbly they want to be able to take
advantage of that and when it comes to
nuclear weapons as well you talked about
you know 77 years ago when those two
bombs shocked the world yeah and we
thought my goodness you know we have
these inventions that we come up with
terribly in war you know from going back
to the longbow the gatling gun the tank
and so forth they changed the
characteristic of war never we invented
something that could wipe out humanity
so yes we had the cold war we had the
arms race but then there were agreements
there were treaties there was a
recognition that if you had arms you
know nuclear weapons and i did as well i
won't invade you you weren't invaded
that was like when we were great i've
got them you've got them so we cancelled
each other out exactly so that led to a
reduction in these treaties and so on
now a number of nations have got them
not only that you don't have just city
killers you have tactical low yield
numbers
what are these low yield tactical
weapons because is it halfway house no
these are tiny nuclear weapons but
they're still a nuclear weapon and this
is what russia putin is threatening to
use but if he uses this one he then you
cross the threshold of a nuclear weapon
being used where does that take you to
and the trouble is as we heard from our
national security advisor only a week
ago saying that there aren't the back
channels that there were during the cold
war we don't have the conversations
behind the scenes to say what you just
heard by our president don't take it out
of context you know it's okay it was
meant for a domestic audience that has
gone my worry is through miscalculation
through a misunderstanding we can
actually see us escalate towards
armageddon um when you look at russia uh
and and i said the other day that the
ukraine war is is everybody's war and
we've talked in the past you and i have
taught on the radio you know could we do
more logistically we're doing what we
can do you believe that ukraine
can win this war is going to win this
war or will russia just continue and
ultimately
will have that victory though
it's looking like a frozen wall you just
had a really interesting conversation
about the state of british you know uk
economics yeah what's the real problems
what's the headwinds what's the cause of
stagflation it's because of what's going
on in ukraine and we didn't have the
forethought to go in and stand up to
russia prior to the invasion we now
realize that that grain that's not
allowed to come out in the scale that it
needs to from odessa is the fueling the
cost of living crisis here oil and gas
is up because of ukraine why didn't we
step up and you're absolutely right to
point out what goes on in ukraine won't
stay in ukraine no one right russia is
now on the front foot they're setting
the agenda we're watching what's going
on well we need to really start to stand
up to russia
let's talk about standing up to them um
what what would you do put yourself in
the foreign secretary shoes or whatever
what would you do
as a nation right now to make this
and i try and do this show every night
for the people who are watching i don't
want to be i'll be accused and so will
you at some point tomorrow of
warmongering we're not we're being
realistic we're putting the points out
there what should people at home be
thinking about well you're absolutely
right to point that question what can we
do yeah i went to edessa to ask that
very question or to pose an idea a
proposal and that's is that you go to
the general assembly the u.n general
assembly bypassing the security council
where russia and china will veto you get
a resolution that turns odessa into a
humanitarian safe haven that will allow
a coalition of the willing to create a
maritime force to protect the shipping
those grain ships to get out at the
moment they're
only moving out one at a time i have a
theory because this is russia's solution
that all they want to see is those 70
ships that got caught up during the
invasion there are about 70 ships from
across the world
russia is going to let them out once
it's done that they'll then actually
attack odessa because that's their
long-term plan they want to isolate
ukraine they want to make it landlocked
because that'll really strangle the
economy and it also affect because they
usually weaponize grain as well um does
our government does the un need to be
in basic terms you talk about that do we
continue to support the ukraine more
logistically can you ever see a
situation where there would be foot
traffic from soldiers on the ground or
not well once you've got that maritime
force in place and yes you are going to
have to look russia in the eye all this
talk during the leadership elections of
trying to emulate thatcher why don't
emulate churchill let's stand up and
lead europe let's leave instead on the
front foot we are a p5 member of the un
security council i see no leadership in
the west whatsoever at the moment we
need to get back to that
step forward lead other countries and
have a solution that stands up to russia
uh you brought up we've talked in detail
about the world order you brought up the
leadership election um
you were one of boris johnson's fiercest
critics yesterday on this show i had
jacob rees-mogg just just watch this if
you can
be nice to play it
no it's all right we we're getting on
with it oh no no it's fine i'm cool
great the overall score card for boris
johnson is that we have had an
absolutely fine prime minister and it is
very sad that he has been forced out
thoughts on that
well it wasn't just me i actually put my
hand up and said the style of government
less the policy is the reason why we
can't go forward we are hemorrhaging the
trust with the british people we want to
earn that trust again with any attempt
to win the next general election then
we're going to have to do that under a
new leader and it wasn't just me but
then you had a swathe i think 50
ministers resigned on one day so we're
here jacob
yeah but let's talk about penny morning
because she backed penny more than she
came from absolutely nowhere she ended
up third she was knocked out what i
don't get politically well i do but i
want to ask you this question she and
liz trust were quite vociferous in their
criticism of each other and the other
day she delivered what can only be
described as an oscar-winning speech
saying liz trust is the greatest thing
since sliced bread and i always knew
she'd make a great prime minister is
that how you feel about liz trust now
i'm not gonna make a comment because one
of the criticisms i had of this entire
campaign is the blue on blue thus taking
chunks out of each other we're
forgetting that we shouldn't be actually
just appealing to our base our base
actually wants to be led and at the
moment we're following them doesn't your
base still want boris johnson 71 of the
tory membership want boris johnson as
the next prime minister well that's not
an option what's happened is is that the
mps
and so many mps have decided boris is
not the future therefore we're now going
through this process that's where we are
that's the reality check we have to face
but how do you answer the criticism and
people say to me kylie being
undemocratic how do you answer the
british people who will say the 70
something million of us have 180 000
tory members who pay 25 quid are going
to get to decide on the next prime
minister when 14 million people whether
you like him or love him voted for boris
johnson and you lot to safeguard your
seats threw him out should there not
have been a general election it's a bit
more complicated i know but do you not
think the people should have that
decision where i agree is that we should
remove the base the party membership for
making that judgment that's exactly
right i believe that mps who have to
work most directly who make up the
government get to decide who the prime
minister should be whilst in government
when we're in opposition it's a
different matter go back to michael
hezeltein and margaret thatcher's time
that didn't go to the beginning i don't
i did it's a personal opinion i'm
entitled to it like you or i don't think
anybody should entertain down the street
unless they've got a mandate from the
british people i've said it from all
that uh you're not going to say who
you're backing would you accept the
foreign secretary's job from liz trust
or rishi soon act because all the
defense ministers because you've done it
all why are you not in the government
you must be in the government right it's
for the choice for the next prime
minister to do so what i would say is
that we do need fiscal responsibility
that's what the conservatives are known
for you've just had some statistics
we've had some statistics from the bank
of england showing where our country is
actually going to be basically british
final points and you've been great many
people are saying soon that can't win we
should put this to bed make her prime
minister and get on doing the things
that you're talking about the economic
crisis the situation in the world would
you not agree with that we're still a
democracy we have to go through the
process
the summer's almost over fifth of
september we'll have a new prime
minister a new prime minister and pm
himself will be back in the chair to buy
a silverwood as ever a pleasure thank
you very much indeed to him right next
to an uncensored millions of households
are phasing host pipe bands after the
driest july and decades as forecasters
warn of another heat wave i'm going to
tell you that when you come back from
the break i am so nervous about the next
bit we'll see you in three don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is talk tv
uh right look at this welcome back what
a perfect evening for a spot of free
bedtime gardening the birds are merrily
chirping the leaves are gently
fluttering and i'm about to water my
plants what a joy it is to be alive but
wait a minute what can i hear
[Music]
good lord is stop and search back maybe
but this time they'll be searching you
for one of these bad boys my friends do
you like that apparently there are
already hosepipe bands in place across
the south of england today yorkshire
water have warned that if the current
dry spell continues they'll be forced to
take action now i'm not sure many of you
will remember the sweltering summer of
76. i was a mere lad back then always
looking for an opportunity to play with
my anyway it was the last time there was
a blanket ban across this country the
situation was so bad that many of us
were left without tap water people were
told to pour washing up water down the
loo to save on flushing you could only
bathe in five inches of water and this
is my favorite a major government thing
was you can bathe with a friend
see he even takes up most of the bath
for goodness sake i'm running
to do to do hello how are you oh the
chair's nearly gone there we go ah i'm
joined now by lawyer paul britton this
man who says you should snitch on your
neighbors if you see them using a hose
pipe in banned areas the head of the
institute of environmental management
this man martin baxter baxter even we
did my friends try out of breath to get
a chief executive from one of the water
companies but they were all busy
watering their gardens and swimming in
their pools but before we talk to these
two i want to start
with tom bradshaw president of the
national farmers union tom good evening
thank you very much indeed for joining
us um this is your farm and one only has
to look at the ground around you to see
what decimation it has caused and the
reason i wanted to do this differently
tonight was we've talked about the cost
of living the lack of water i suspect
will affect your crops
and that will affect price is that right
yeah you're absolutely correct the you
can see the very parched landscape
behind me here and the lack of rainfall
is
causing huge concern for all sectors of
agriculture but if you think about those
that are using irrigation that grow our
vegetables
they've been using their irrigation now
for several months the dry weather's
still ongoing and many of them now are
running out of water and the impact
that's going to have is it's going to
mean that the yields are lower the
potatoes are going to be smaller the
onions will be smaller and ultimately
they'll be less available as we move
forward through the season what i don't
understand tom is the infrastructure
and i talk as a layman because they
don't really have any experience of this
but it seems to me that it always rains
in the winter i spent several years in
manchester it rained for the first 63
days i was here so we've got all the
rain in the winter and yet come july
there's a hose where does it go tom
i know i'd love to know the answer that
question
every year we pump millions of liters of
water into the north sea and i think
we've got to start thinking about water
strategically so that we can make sure
that we really can underwrite our food
security we can't afford to pump that
water into the north sea we need to be
capturing it we need to be storing it so
that we can utilize it in these dry
summer months because we're very lucky
in this country that we do have an
abundance of water in the winter and
then when we have a dry spell we should
be able to have ample water available
for irrigation or for your hose pipes so
that we can grow the crops that everyone
needs and then the other thing of course
is we're an island so there's water all
the way around us in terms of
what we were talking about earlier this
this cost of living crisis because so
many people talk about it but i'm trying
to put it in real terms for people for
foodstuffs for fruit and for vegetables
from what you see as the president of
the nfu what will this do to food prices
this water shortage
i mean we'd already seen the critical uh
shortages of food because of the crisis
going on in the in the ukraine and
that's driven food prices higher and i'm
afraid with this very dry weather that
we're seeing now we're seeing the dairy
prices are beginning to rise they need
to do that so they can afford to feed
their animals over the winter and carry
on producing the milk so it's going to
to make sure that our farmers have
sustainable returns and fair returns
retailers have really got to make sure
they do give them the rewards that are
required so that we can reinvest in next
year's crops that we can invest in the
infrastructure to store the water and
the irrigation facilities and i think
that inevitably it's putting an upward
pressure on prices um martin baxter i'll
bring you in what's your view of this
situation i guess there are people in
this country that would say that's not
my problem i'm gonna have a shower i'm
gonna water my garden i'm gonna wash my
car
how bad is it
well it is bad because uh clearly you
know we we've just come from tom he's
got significant challenges um and if we
don't have enough water to um supply
people then you know people at the end
of the line end up without any water at
all so we really must address this issue
um we're in a situation where
um you know
extensive heat you know 40 odd degrees
um really dries out our water resources
but what he said where's all the water
in the winter gone why are we not sell
it what's that plant somebody said that
a desalination plant's been apparently a
massive one summer in the uk has been
there for 12 years and nobody started it
so there's a big challenge one is about
leakage we lose and you won't believe
the stat but it is true we lose
three
billion liters of water
from leakage every
day
three billion liters of water leaked
everything and that's down to the
companies so they were still making
record profits they are and
dealing with that is one of the really
big challenges now we have a water
network that if you laid it out it would
go around the equator eight and a half
times so that's two hundred and twenty
thousand miles worth and i can't well
then all underground
and you have to find the leagues and
then you have to dig them up if they're
in cities you're digging up roads people
don't like it is this another example
with the grace of respect we were
talking earlier about you know energy
companies these are massive
conglomerates in this country making
billions of pounds worth of profits and
delivering pretty bad service to its
customers isn't it
well i would definitely agree with that
comment in terms of
not having enough investment the
question is why don't they have the
investment in part the regulatory
framework is set by government
over overseen by off-what and
implemented by off-what and ultimately
what they're looking at is what's the
price to the consumer so we've got we've
got pipes with leaks in and we and we
pour a lot into the to the north sea and
everywhere around the coast we've got a
hose pipe man you're my favorite guest
for ages uh paul britain you're a lawyer
you'd have me you'd have me shot my
neighbor man you're just you're just
making money out of people's misery man
aren't you well i think you're
exaggerating it but you know if if your
neighbor is using a hose pipe during and
they're in a region where there is a ban
in place then i think the advice would
be speak to them in the first instance
approach them in a neighborly way i mean
it depends how you get on with your
neighbors obviously but uh if you get on
well then what would you do what did you
do in a serious night if you woke up one
morning in your lovely house looked
looked over your your fence or whatever
it is and and saw your neighbor just
quickly doing the pansies or washing the
car what would you do i would say jeremy
can you not water your i'm not listening
to you
but i'm saying would you would you go
and have a conversation because we brits
are quite good at not saying anything
aren't we well i i would probably have a
word and just say that there is i think
what you'll find nine times out of ten
is that your neighbor probably doesn't
realize that there's a ban well here's
the thing there's a thousand pound fine
um
i i get the feeling
with everything that's going on at the
moment in terms of the cost of living
crisis the order of the world whether
it's a hose pipe bam the threat
something
we are quite good i think this country
when we come together in a crisis we've
become uh seemingly a lot stronger do
you think people will respond or do you
think i'm just going to play the devil's
advocate here do you think people will
go i don't care if you're tuning in this
is not my opinion i'm saying i don't
care about a hose pipe ban i don't care
about the environment i don't care about
the crops i'm not bothered about i'm
going to wash my car i'm going to have
four showers a day and they can do one
what would you say to those people i
mean sadly if that was an attitude
adopted by too many people
then we would be in a situation where
the
the water supplies the water's authority
would restrict the amount of water
coming through um they can restrict the
times of days that certain things are
done you mentioned that
you know you can wash your car but it's
also a leisure boat fill your swimming
pool out maintain your pond clean your
windows don't water your grass but grass
your neighbour up gosh and they were up
did you like that
well out of your mouth not mine but uh
but that's what you're saying but we
have to take responsibility i'm saying
speak to your neighbours and if if it
comes to it then of course then you can
report them to local authorities and
martin what do you see from the
government what do you want to see a big
apartment from the government what do
you want to see from these companies to
make this situation as we heard from tom
bradshaw better because it's going to
affect all of us in the long run right
yeah
and it will definitely continue to be a
problem climate change will help to
drive that um what we need is three
things so one is that we need to support
a reduction in demand um by being more
efficient only half of households have a
water meter and households that have a
hot water meter
use on average a third less water than
those per person so get everybody on a
meter that then starts you know pay as
you use that's that seems pretty fair
[Music]
[Music]
hey sir
it's absolutely critical that we really
view water as part of our national
infrastructure and to underwrite our
food security we've got to make sure
that we get our water infrastructure in
place climate change is a very real
threat as we move forward and we've got
to make sure we learn from what we're
going through at the moment so that
we're better prepared and we're more
resilient when it happens again paul
bradshaw uh paul britton martin baxter
thank you both very much to all of you
for joining us right next on uncensored
it used to be called piers's pack it's
called jesus journals it's cheap but it
works and tonight we're joined by talk
tv's legend kevin o'sullivan and dr
sonja adesara don't go anywhere i'm
coming back in three
[Music]
about your mobile bill with sky mobile
you can get two gig of data for just six
pounds a month that's the uk's cheapest
annual data plan amongst big networks
and unlike most other networks we won't
raise our prices mid-contract so get the
uk's cheapest annual data plan amongst
big networks with two gig for only six
pounds a month and no price raises mid
contract
all on our award-winning network sky
mobile value you can believe in
at mars electrical we're programmed to
keep our customers happy that's why we
offer free next day delivery when you
order a domestic appliance from us just
one of the many reasons we've been given
a 5 star rating on trustpilot we've
samsung washing machines from only 399
pounds and american fresh freezers from
just 899 pounds
you could save yourself a few bumps
no not you bob find your next appliance
at mars electrical dot co dot uk marks
electrical why wouldn't you
there's over a century of chinese wisdom
in every part of tiger ball its unique
blend of active herbal ingredients is
used across the world to provide
effective relief from pain when you need
it most
trust tiger bomb to work where it hurts
attention headaches try tiger bomb
weight
look at us
our lives are a hive of activity
so why does most health and life
insurance just stand there
doing nothing
unless the worst happens oh this is my
kind of speed vitality is different
our insurance doesn't just protect you
it also rewards you when you get active
with everything from weekly coffees to
half-price gym membership and right now
you'll even get up to two months
cashback on your premiums
this holiday just us two well it
reminded me of how good our years
together would be
this is the moment i think about
whenever i think of us
find your moments that matter with piano
cruises
this summer what stores have all you
need to get your garden glowing compost
lawn feed weed killer to wood stain
bedding plants garden tools bird seed to
tomato feed come see for yourself we're
open seven days a week time to brighten
up your outdoor space what stores
variety value and choice
anna stayed at this hotel and paid this
price
laura stayed at the same hotel and paid
a lot less
how well anna found the hotel on her
usual website laura on the other hand
used travago to compare offers from
major booking sites and found a great
deal
hotel trivago
this is the way to sell your car
the your car gets picked up from home
for freeway
this is the motorway
welcome back my friends on censor with
me jeremy carl and it's now time for
jezza's journals tonight i'm delighted
to be joined by good friend of mine talk
tv's presenter uh tv kev o'sullivan and
an old adversary uh interestingly dr
sonia adesara is here and it's taking me
three months to get an appointment with
the gp how are you very good how are you
are you well sir i'm very very well joe
much to discuss and you're across the
table with each other let's start with
um the cost of living crisis this is
i mean we've heard so much about it but
this is real and it seems to affect
almost every part of our lives and
they're saying that 10 million people in
this country will be plunged below the
poverty line what would you do what
would you say
yeah 10 million households going into
fuel poverty what does that mean that
means elderly people getting into
hospital from from from from being too
cold that means children being too cold
that they can't sleep it's just um
it is horrific and i and i you know
already we already i have so many
families that i speak to my clinic who
are already struggling and the fact that
that's set to go worse and we can enter
this winter um with with with fuel
prices going up and people not being
able to pay their bills i find very
frightening and on top of that we have a
vacant government we have a prime
minister that's on holiday i'm not quite
sure who the chancellor is right now and
we've got two leadership rivals who are
talking about what woke toilets and i
don't know diversity offices where where
is the plan where is the measures to
intervene right now because we know that
families are thrilling
and families are being pushed into
poverty and into destitution as well
really really good point kev and and
people have talked about how the
leadership election has created
stagnation and the government isn't
governing many people are saying get rid
of the leadership thing let's get on
with it how bad is this cost of living
crisis and what does the government need
to do well i mean we are on the edge of
a kind of catastrophe that we're going
into uncharted territory
we all know that energy prices in
october will rocket because of the uh
price cap changing so they're going to
go up to for the average household about
three and a half or three thousand three
hundred pounds we only learned today
that actually now the energy com
companies are going to be allowed to
raise the price cap every three months
so that's going to carry on so by
january we're talking about 3 800 and
more and more and more and today we had
the biggest uh interest rate rise for 27
years uh inflation is going to go up to
13 maybe 15
this is a nightmare this is frightening
i had an economist on my show today and
he just said this is terrifying but but
it's it is terrifying we all agree right
what i want to know is briefly what do
we do i mean you talk about the prime
minister because you don't like him
where are the mps there's 680 mps back
in their constituencies why are they not
in westminster dealing with this for the
people where is that government where is
our government they need to intervene
and they need to integrate now okay so
we energy prices are going to be going
up in october and again in january at
the same time what have we heard again
record record profits for the energy
corporations the government can step in
there and then the winner not the green
levy what about that well i think you
know the windfall tax was was a good
idea but they need to go through with it
i think they can backtrack the windfall
tax to collect more money from that and
also they can extend the win for attack
so so there was a i guess a get out
cause that allowed and they said if
you're investing the money then you
cannot pay that tax and it allows these
women allows the energy corporations to
basically not pay up to a third of that
of that windfall tax so they can tighten
up that legislation to get that money
back and then help struggling families
they can do that right now vat cut on
fuel would make sense cut the green levy
i think that the government should be
doing what it can right now to help
people in the next few months
liz trust has promised to do this if she
wins the battle and it looks as if she's
pointless battle i just give up will she
seem like it's gonna hope in hell and by
the way it is ridiculous that we have to
wait until september the fifth at this
critical time uh but uh yes we must cut
get rid of the uh 25 we pay on our
electricity bills and the eight percent
we pay on our energy bills generally uh
which goes to the green levy that is the
green levy we must you know you know
tomorrow right tomorrow hold on a second
tomorrow is one month until the new
prime minister is announced in this
country i think they should they they
should be here for that month doing
something but i want to move on because
i think he's on holiday right our prime
minister right now well you you don't
lie
yeah but but
what what are most doctors aren't they
but no no doctors have no doubt
why you can't get an appointment
and this is this is not a joke this is
this is millions of families going into
poverty we will we will see we will see
people die as a result of i agree
you said sonia that uh fuel poverty
they'll go into on october actually 10
million people will be plunged below the
poverty
you're doing it again let's move on uh
very quickly hosepipe ben would you
snitch in your neighbor uh def no i
would not i definitely would not and i
don't like the hose pipe band because uh
first of all uh the water companies they
leak billions and billions of gallons of
water a year because of their rubbish
pipe systems uh their executives get
paid massive amounts
couldn't get one and they blame it
couldn't get one
that has 84 million in profit wastes 90
million of liters of water per day
ridiculous right so the government can
intervene get the water companies to to
tighten up and and or let's nationalize
them okay they're not we've been we've
had the same story year after year and i
said it will get worse
nationalization is always a decision
let's talk about prince harry before you
two have a bun fight second lawsuit
prince harry back in the news uh didn't
want security then offered to pay for it
it's not looking great for him is it to
be fair yeah this case is ridiculous i
mean he he started to sue the government
the home office because uh they would
not provide him with police protection
when he brought his family over uh and
they said well that's because you're no
longer a frontline royal
so he's now launched a new legal battle
because he then asked well i'll pay for
it myself and we quite rightly said to
prince harry hey look it's not a sort of
commercial service oh when i'm over can
i pay for a few cops we don't do that so
now he is suing the home office to say
you must allow me to pay for my own
coppers so far the home office has spent
90 000 wow
and rising on this this man uh is a
pernicious problem i i i'm completely
with him would you agree
so he wants to pay for his insecurity so
when he comes to this country him and
his family are
protected i don't think you'll never
agree with anything that i said you
can't pay for property
and his security will be at risk
um you can't say here's a few quid can i
have some coppers from scotland yard to
look after me it doesn't go like that
bring your own private security and pay
for it i've said it before listen if you
wanna be the royal family absolutely go
and take your 112 million dollars very
very quickly um what shall i pick uh
batgirl film canned for 19. 19 million
dollars we've got two minutes without
even being shown it's too woke isn't it
well i was 10 years in hollywood i've
covered the showbiz industry for a long
long time i've seen many massive
hollywood flops huge flops i have never
ever heard of a studio saying we spent
90 million
90 million dollars on batgirl it's so
bad so i'm not going to release it at
all we're going to junk it unbelievable
and dr uh sonia disarro comes out with
the grace line of the night uh a waste
of money and you think that the people
in glasgow just repeat this is barking
but have a go
i just think given what we're talking
about spoken about today the fact that
we just they've just thrown 17 million
down the drain is um no you've said that
the people in glasgow should be
compensated if their lives were
disrupted by filming so the story was
the people in glasgow were very angry
they were very angry because a lot of
disruption happened and they're very
angry now that that film has been
cancelled so if their lives were
disrupted then whatever paid them
conversation
a lot of money around the final word is
it's too woke in other words you go woke
and you go broke uh there you go uh 30
seconds um south end football club have
made a massive massive mistake by
renaming uh one of their stands the west
stand the rose west stand can you help
me out well it's a local estate agent
called gilbert and rose they sponsored
this stand and so it's called the west
so south end football club i've called
it the gilbert and rose west stand
they're rethinking that now they didn't
think it through
i just think no one cares about the
story do they yeah i do i think it's
really funny
are you two going out for dinner
afterwards i can't imagine the
conversation might be fun i could
nationalize it
so so for all of us we agree we haven't
got a lot of time but the the the cost
of living crisis is the most important
thing the government need to get on it
they need to come back to westminster
and everybody needs to pull together and
what i would say to everybody is is that
it's very easy to hear the headlines and
see the stuff it is
just just when you go to bed tonight 10
million people in this country under the
poverty line the fifth richest nation in
the world that is absolutely ludicrous
and needs to be changed kevin o'sullivan
back tomorrow morning for mike graham at
10. indeed dr sonia decided i'll
hopefully get an appointment with you
very soon loved having you both on uh
well that's it from me that is week one
done well tomorrow as well uh piers
morgan not here for another month you
lucky people thank you for watching i'm
back at 6 30 in the morning uh breakfast
for friday no sleep for me that's it for
tomorrow quasiquating on my show
tomorrow wherever you are whatever
you're doing make it uncensored good
night have a great one tour
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the beast this simply does not wash look
who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm soros solomon the uk is
heading towards a recession that's
predicted to last longer than a year the
bank of england says this winter will be
the start of an economic downturn that
will last for five consecutive quarters
making it the longest since the 2008
financial crisis
taiwan says china has fired 11 ballistic
missiles into waters near its coastline
beijing has been carrying out military
drills since u.s politician nancy pelosi
visited the island this week and u.s
basketball player brittany grinner has
been sentenced to nine years in prison
after pleading guilty to smuggling drugs
into russia the olympic medalist was
found with cannabis oil vape cartridges
in february well that's all for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you